and as the dust settles on the first
wave of free agency we will take a
closer look at what some teams did and
didn't do but one thing that bears
mentioning the cincinnati bengals and
there was a report that they were going
to be active
in the early stages of free agency and
they have been active in the early
stages of free agency spending more
money than they've ever spent
and i look i don't think that mike brown
the owner of the team decided to do this
because he's sick and tired of being
called cheap he's been called cheap for
so long he should be used to it by now
i'd love to know at what level of the
organization this came from
and and really what they're trying to do
and unless and until someone tells me
otherwise my belief is going to be
they're just trying to win
they are right they're trying to win
that's that's it they're building their
their defense stunk last year
you know it stunk it wasn't good they
they got obliterated in the run game i
mean
i want to make sure i got this right but
i'm pretty sure they were la they were
last in football in rush defense oh yeah
well you know what you do when that's
that's a problem yours you sign a big mf
er like dj reader i mean he is one of
the best run stopping interior
defensive tackles in football so that's
awesome i mean that's a great signing i
know people like you know it's not a
superstar name but this is the kind of
player that makes defenses great and
he's never going to get headlines the
stats are never going to really tell you
what he does he
commands double teams creates mosh pits
in the middle of a defense or offense
and then hey train wayne's a corner i
mean listen you know we you and i you're
a mr vikings he's got a lot of talent he
can cover people for sure you know he's
a little bit of a pass interference
issue doesn't always play the ball well
but he can run he's got size you know
and i think they're probably hoping
their their coaching can clean up some
of these things so i like that and of
course franchising aj green things are
going in the right direction with the
cincinnati bengals
yeah and who knows what ultimately
happens with aj green does he want to be
there will he be traded will he be
traded during the season if the season
goes off the rails early but they are
trying to
and again it's i don't think they're
trying to change anyone's mind they're
just trying to win and and we know that
these kinds of moves don't necessarily
guarantee you're going to win but you've
got to spend money the minimum cash
expenditure under the new cba is up to
90 percent that's nine cents of every or
99 wait 90 cents of every dollar has to
be spent at some point you've got to
spend it and they are spending it and
we'll see if it makes them any better
but look i don't hate the bengals
contrary to the belief of some who don't
like the fact that i pointed out that
the smoke signals coming from joe
burrows suggested he was thinking about
trying to pull an eli manning oh by the
way he was thinking about it he's not
now uh i i'm all for the bengals being
competitive i think every fan base
deserves a team that is in contention at
least every third year these long
droughts aren't good for the sport where
a city becomes essentially forgotten
like the browns like the bengals and
other places where we just never see a
team rise up and compete for an
opportunity to get to the postseason
opportunity to get to the super bowl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports